um I just want to talk about what
happened in the English Channel
um four people dead the freezing Waters
the dark the the phone call that was
made in the early hours of the morning I
mean it's impossible not to look at the
details and be very moved by it what
would labor do
you're right when we talk about the
details when you hear about what
happened it's it's horrific there's no
other word for it it's truly you know
deeply upsetting and an awful to to hear
what happened and you know I think it
really it should be a wake-up call it's
really underscores the fact that we need
to do something about people who are
being smuggled with white people
traffickers by criminal gangs across the
the channel now you know we know that
there's been a lot of discussion about
this in the media and so on and in
Parliament you know we've been saying
for a long time that rather than spend
money on things like the Rwanda policy
which we think is unethical and
unworkable that money would be better
spent beefing up the capacity the
National Crime agency to go after the
criminal gangs who are smuggling these
people in the first place it's easy
Southern Dumbo isn't it you know if it
was easy to break up the people of
traffickers then yeah any government
would do that wouldn't they I mean I
just look at what Interpol says on that
you know there's a relatively low risk
of detection prosecution and arrest
compared to other activities of
transmission organized crime and it's
because the relationship between the
criminals and the migrants as a
temporary one so the criminals are
really hard to trace they're unknown to
the people they're smuggling that you
know they hide behind pseudonyms they
use Rental Vehicles different mobile
numbers I mean if Labor's not going to
be just failed to just you know bang a
bit more money to the National Crime
agency and suddenly it's all going to be
sorted well hard problems are what
government has to deal with you know
High problems whether it's what we're
discussing now or the really other big
issues like the climate emergency or all
of the other challenges that we face you
know it is government's job ultimately
to take on these difficult issues and
yes it's not the case of just snapping
your fingers and making things go right
you know it does require hard work Focus
rolling up your sleeves sitting down at
the table making sure that you're really
delivering the program that you talk
about and you know it is one of the
wider problems not just in relation to
this issue but across the piece so the
government members of government members
of the conservative party are so
distracted by their own internal Party
politics within Parliament and trying to
hang on to their jobs and doing all of
their their horse trading and worried
about rebellions here and there they're
not focused on delivering the job which
is which is tacking the really big
issues we Face let's focus on what labor
would do and would you open more routes
to people to claim Asylum legally in the
UK because obviously one of the issues
is that there aren't very many safe and
legal routes if you're not from one of
the sort of designated countries that
has them like Hong Kong Ukraine and
Afghanistan would you like to see it
easier for people to claim Asylum so we
need to make some really important
changes around for instance replacing
the Dublin agreement making sure that
that is there for a safe reunions family
reunions and so on I think the other
part of the of the equation which is
really important as well though is to
make sure that when people are in the UK
the applications are processed and
fairly but speedily and this is one of
the really big problems in the UK isn't
it that's the thing because at the
minute it's you can't get to the UK in a
safe and legal route right if you're
going to only be able to claim Asylum
when you're in the UK that's why come on
a small boat exactly and that's one of
the problems that the Home Secretary you
know found very difficult
well the recent hearing that the Home
Secretary had you know she wasn't able
to explain how the policies which the
conservatives are proposing would help
people to make applications and safe
routes into the country and what we know
is that you need those safe and legal
routes but you also need to make sure
that you have the investment here so
that the Asylum applications can be
processed and if they're and and quick
way because you know at the moment if we
see people in hotel accommodation for
months years on end and that's bad for
the people involved it racks up the bill
in terms of paying for that
accommodation and it's bad for the
overall system okay we've just heard
from uh Pat Cullen of the Royal College
of Nursing saying that if there isn't a
resolution then we can expect strikes
continuing into the new year into
January which obviously is going to be
um you know desperate news for the NHS
and and it's already under Russia
nurses have said they want a pay rise
that's five percent above inflation is
that affordable
well look as um the shadow Secretary of
State for health and and others and the
opposition has said you know that that
19 you know is not going to be
affordable but the point is uh there
should be a negotiation about avoiding
these strikes going ahead and coming to
a resolution and you know if you take a
step back and think how the government
has behaved in relation to the nurses
and other NHS workers and indeed
different sectors across the across the
economy and across public the public
sector the government have not been
willing to negotiate they have stepped
back they have let these problems
develop or go without the solution and
actually as I said in in response to one
of your earlier questions the job of
government is to roll up your sleeves
and try and sort out difficult problems
and this is a difficult problem but it
is one where we believe the government
should roll up their sleeves get get to
the negotiating table and avoid these
strikes that no one wants to see happen
any other nurses don't want them to go
ahead would you like to see the labor
government in Wales do that then as well
where there's also strikes going on well
we want to see across the country
strengths averted you know and the point
is
the way that you avert strikes is to
negotiate with trade unions with workers
representatives and try and get a deal
because no one wants strikes to go ahead
you know the nurses do not want to go on
strike if no one in any industry wants
to go on strike and as it and the public
don't want to see the strikes either and
it really is the job of government
rather than standing back rather than
giving up because it's too hard rather
than threatening you know new
legislation to to to as they would see
it deal with the problem they need to
roll up their sleeves sit down at their
table negotiate a solution well I mean I
guess the government would say they've
said what the offer is because they're
going to go along with the pay review
body which is around four percent for
most nurses so so what would Labor's
position be then so ultimately it is the
responsibility of government to find a
solution
you're the government in Waiting what
would be a fair pay rise for nurses
would it be 7.5 like they've accepted in
Scotland well the point of having a
negotiation is that you have that
negotiation to work out what the the pay
deal is and what the other terms of
their agreement are but if you're in a
position you can get a bit of pressure
on the government by saying what your
position would be the the position that
we're putting the pressure on the
government to do is to negotiate is to
get around the table and to roll up
their sleeves and do the the difficult
but critical work of government which
has come to a solution and that's how we
would avert strikes and that's how we'd
make sure that the health services is a
better position but you know if we can
just say one other one other point which
is really important which is that the
Health Service you know has been run
down it's been run down for 12 years and
pays a really important issue but it's
also a lack of lack of Staff you know
there's real problems with Recruitment
and Retention which is why we proposed
the biggest expansion of the NHS
Workforce in its history funded by
scrapping for non-dong tax status okay
thank you very much for being on the
program today explaining some of Labor's
proposals James Murray